but I'm back champ is a legend one of
India's most respected veteran actors
with the career spanning almost 40 years
he is racked up nearly 13 million
followers on Twitter but more
importantly appeared in more than 180
Indian films he is in London to promote
his new Hindi film shamitabh and if
you're a fan of mr. Pak Chan you will
know all about him if not this is what
you have been missing
Cheerilee did you order this dish I did
man know what the problem is first time
in London hmm from India when I made the
pleasure of mr. Gatsby's acquaintance I
discovered a man of fine breathing very
interesting today all right
yes and that was hitting The Great
Gatsby there a Matar back camera
delighted to say joins us there in
central London mr. Bach chan welcome to
London thank you so much for having me
on your show not at all not at all we
saw a big red London bus there and in
one of those clips and have you shot
some of the film in London yes we have
some of the portions were done in the in
the law courts and some of the streets
of London and the red bus that you see
the typical icon off of London traffic
was done on one of the streets of London
so tell us about the new film what is
the plot this is a story of two
individuals who have different talents
and there's a journalist who discovers
that if the two individuals were to come
together they would achieve success she
manages to do that both of them get
together and move ahead and then ego
starts to play one things that the other
is is not important enough oh it will
not be possible to succeed without the
other and then what eventually happens
is what the story is all about it's I
think quite a unique plot because my
character gives his voice to the other
character so when you hear the other
person you will hear actually my voice
yeah it was unique because I have to
record the
entire script beforehand about you know
the entire script was pre-recorded then
we played the recording during the shoot
and then we read up the whole thing
again because we have to match the
facial expect on placated but different
but we saw you there and in the Great
Gatsby we saw clip there of Great Gatsby
let me ask you after your experience of
them of being in something like that
Hollywood or Bollywood for you I think
the Indian film industry is fine so far
for me I doubt if there will be you know
any space for me in Hollywood but Gatsby
was done as a as a friendly gesture to
baz lurman who I came to know during his
trip to India and this was just a
friendly gesture I doubt very much if
there will be anything else coming my
way mr. Bach Chan
my colleagues in the studio Isabelle and
Jackie very keen to talk to you
Jacqueline yes
I just wanted amitab if you were a
cricket fan I think I'm right thinking
that you are and all Friday India play
England in a decider to get to the final
of the of the try series and I wondered
who you thought might win that match yes
we need to win that because if we don't
then we're probably out of the tri
series we've lost to England we've lost
to Australia in the in the initial two
games the third game was a wash art
because of rain yes we need to win this
one what do you think of India's chances
at the World Cup of defending their
trophy well as an Indian I always think
that we should win it again and I wish
my team all the best and hope that they
do it another time it we've already done
it twice and this will be a third time
just one more quick sports one if we put
you in the biggest stadium in India with
Sachin Tendulkar who would be the most
famous or popular such Anton Duke oh
yeah I wanted to chip in if I may I was
just looking on Twitter and I saw that
the Pope and you've actually got three
times as many followers on Twitter as
the Pope
true that you waved your friends like
him every Sunday yes actually it's
something that happened many many years
ago in 1982 I had a near-fatal accident
on one of my sets enormous died and
somehow I lived to you know be in front
of your in front of your cameras today
and every Sunday thereafter for these
past 30 odd years the people come out to
the gates and I go out and meet them
it's a wonderful way to connect with the
well-wishers who just want to see my
face a wave of the hand sign some
autographs take some pictures that's hot
I know I'm a table I I do it myself I I
do it on Mondays I know exactly that
feelings you know what I think when I
look well night when I look at you my
friend I think you look very like Robert
De Niro have you been told that no this
is the first time I'm first time first
time for everything I wanted to ask you
I know you've been married to Y foot for
42 years and she herself is an MP back
in India and you've been really
influential in India haven't you in
promoting women's rights
um yes she's a member of the Rajya Sabha
which is the upper house and I have I
did enter politics in 84 I fought in
election I won but then I resigned in a
year or two because I was not qualified
to be a politician and just felt it
wasn't something that I knew anything
about as far as social service is
concerned yes I was appointed United
Nations ambassador for the polio drive
in India and after eight years of very
hard work we've now got India polio free
I'm also involved now in the eradication
or the awareness of tuberculosis
diabetes I run from joining up with the
right honourable Keith was who's a
member of parliament here in the British
Parliament and now going to be involved
in the awareness and care for hepatitis
so yes there are many many social causes
that we all attach ourself
- I'm also involved in the Gujarat state
tourism and I'm going to be shortly
doing some campaigns for tourism in much
Pradesh as well
I'm a topic chan lovely talking to you
thank you very much indeed good luck